welcome to the famous Friday and I
believe that whatever goal you have
whatever challenges in front of you
somebody has already solved that you
don't have to come up with every new
idea yourself and the fastest way to
achieve that goal is to find someone
who's done it model the success and
apply it to your business so today's
lesson is take control and is by the
billionaire entrepreneur Ross Perot now
growing up Ross Perot seemed to have a
natural knack for selling he he started
off in his life selling Christmas cards
and magazines and in garden seeds
door-to-door as a way to make some extra
money for himself when he was 12 years
old he wanted to be a paperboy
he wanted to be a newspaper delivery guy
and there was no root for his area
because he lived in Texarkana Texas
which was super dangerous at the time
and so dangerous that the newspaper
didn't have a route there so he went to
go talk to the owner he's 12 years old
he goes talks to the owner and he says
I'd like to open up our route in
Texarkana Texas for you and he
negotiated a higher than normal
Commission because it was so dangerous
in that area and the the the owners like
now this kid is never gonna make it
Perot decided to go and do it he got a
horse so he can deliver the newspapers
by horseback so he could avoid any
would-be muggers who wanted to steal
whatever money they had from him that's
that's taking control later in life Ross
Perot he gets a job at IBM big blue he's
working as a salesman he's hittin all
his sales quarters he's a superstar
salesman top of his class and in all the
salespeople that IBM one year he met his
annual sales target by January 19th so
he's on the rise and he goes and he
talks to his bosses at IBM it's IBM was
a great hardware company we make great
computers we should get into the
software business too
there's great opportunities to sell
software and his boss is looking and say
now we're not interested we're not gonna
do that and so Ross Perot leaves
dejected right he feels like his ideas
have been stomped on they're not
listening to him and and he's sad the
Preston you know the feeling when you've
told your boss about an idea and he or
she stomped all over it and said it's
not we're not gonna go this way so one
day he's sitting getting his haircut
he's feeling a little sad and he picks
up Reader's Digest and he opens it up
and he sees a quote from Henry Thoreau's
Walden that said the mass of men lead
lives of quiet desperation that quote
meant something to him it struck him
right in the heart because he didn't
want to be like most men he didn't want
to give up control of his destiny he
didn't want to be given ideas to his
bosses to have them say no and say we're
gonna put you in this box rosboroughs is
all you're allowed to do so he decided
that day he left his job he borrowed a
thousand dollars from his wife and he
started his own software company it was
called EDS and he used his sales skills
to go out and start getting clients and
within a couple years he had a million
dollars in sales and then a couple years
later continued beyond he became a
billionaire and became a well-known
entrepreneur because he took control of
his life how many times have you been
faced in a situation where you have this
great idea and you pitch somebody and
they say no and that holds you back
imagine if he stayed at IBM he would
have had a career a lifetime that would
have paid him well as a sales guy but a
PeopleSoft but his ideas put him in the
box and saying this is all you're
allowed to do you can't do any more you
could have been a top salesman and
instead he chose to take control of his
destiny become an entrepreneur and
become a billionaire so if you've got a
great idea if you're tired of people
telling you what to do if you're tired
of being put in a box take control just
like Ross Perot did and it might make
you a billionaire to believe those
you're watching like the video you can
see more by clicking the subscribe
button thank you so much I'll see you
soon hi every Kelly English here with
mermaid junkie TV are you on evans
newsletter subscription if not you
should be i read every single one and
you should too
you